let's hear from a few more people folks
who are waiting to chat you can use our
Discord
davidpackman.com
Discord why don't we go next to Seth
from Nebraska Seth from Nebraska welcome
to the David packman show what's on your
mind today
um hi David uh first time caller if you
can hear me I can hear you fine
awesome
um so I had a question my wife and I
were having a discussion actually last
night she is fearful of the future
um when it comes to you know like
Republicans and these policies that
they're
passing is you know they're just not
popular but they keep getting through
and I'm a little bit more optimistic
like
boomers are essentially dying off and
we're zenials and I think Millennials
and gen Z are like the largest voting
block now yeah I just wanted to know
kind of your opinion on
uh if I don't see that this is
sustainable for the Republicans to just
you know push through all these
unpopular ideas
um but you know like I said my wife is
fearful that it's just gonna keep
happening and you know our rights are
going to get you know diminished and
democracy is failing and all that I just
kind of wanted to know your thoughts
well so here's the thing
um let's deal with the The Fear Part
first okay
um one of the
one of the realities is that in the
United States if you live in
Massachusetts Connecticut Minnesota New
Hampshire New Jersey Colorado
the standard of living is measured by
the HDI human development index is very
similar to being in Switzerland Norway
Iceland Hong Kong you know the places
with the highest overall standards of
living with that metric human
development index in those States
regardless of what Republicans do in
Louisiana and regardless of what a
president does to some degree right at
the federal level you can start to
impact states
life on average is going to remain very
good
in the blue states with very high
standard of living and again in order by
HDI it's Massachusetts Connecticut
Minnesota New Hampshire Jersey Colorado
Washington DC Hawaii okay
in other states it's not going to be so
good like so I see that you're calling
for example from Nebraska Nebraska in
terms of HDI I think is kind of like
right in the middle I'm looking at it
um right now it's like it's not terrible
it's not actually Nebraska's okay
Nebraska's 13th in the country so
unfortunately what happens is when you
have democratic presidents and
Democratic houses and senates
things get a little bit better for
everyone and then when you have
Republican presidents and Republican
Governors Etc things get a little worse
for everyone but they get particularly
worse for a lot of these red states that
don't have their own protections already
built in and so sadly listen things can
get bad everywhere there's no question
about it but sadly the first people to
be damaged by Republicans succeeding as
you point out are going to
disproportionately be Republican voters
now what we do with this information
what you and your wife personally do I
don't really know
yeah we just recently had uh I forget
what the bill was is uh the abortion ban
at 12 weeks uh which lumped into there
was transgender affirming care yeah uh
for anyone under I think 19 but then
they also voted on the same day for
permitless concealed carry right uh and
none of those were popular bills at all
we were protesting inside the capitol so
loudly that they had to stop
um the debating inside the chambers but
they still passed it and that was you
know I have a few friends that have
trans kids and you know it's
kind of heavy right now in Nebraska so
everybody's just a little bit worried
thank you for your thoughts though I
appreciate that all right
appreciate the call thank you so much
so yeah all right there he goes why
don't we go next to how about Tristan
from Los Angeles Tristan welcome to the
program
oh hello hello I I have a pretty
open-ended question for you uh just
finished watching succession and I was
wondering if you had any takeaways from
it if you've watched it at all no I
don't even think I have what is that
like a Showtime show or HBO
yes an HBO it's sort of similar to I
guess uh like a Murdoch sort of rain and
the the patriarch is ending and then
handing his crown and it's sort of the
machinations of a large media
conglomerate
I don't have HBO and I haven't seen a
single episode I I my my uh TV show
consumption is really low these days
just because I'm so so busy but a lot of
people have said that it is a great
program but unfortunately I've not seen
it
yep took a little baby and everything
exactly now where are you from Australia
yep okay and you live in the U.S
yeah yeah what's that like what's the
what's the biggest cultural difference
you find in the U.S from Australia
positive or negative either
I don't know I think well how about
positive first
um
there's less of a toll poppy syndrome
here where it to me in Australia
sometimes it can feel like
if you try and do something different
people will try and bring you back into
the fold keep every keep that field of
copies the same height
um but it I think it's guns it's just
it's so normalized here and I could be
talking with very liberal people and
next thing you know like oh yeah we're
gonna go shoot shotguns which is not
negative or positive it's just
incredibly different yeah and in in
Australia is that extremely uh extremely
rare since the laws have been changed
around owning weapons
yeah
yeah it
I I knew a kid who grew up on a farm
who'd shot guns but that's like
literally the only person I knew you
knew one person with guns yeah no that's
definitely very different that is that
is definitely different
yeah I'll have a think about it if I
call back all uh I'll uh maybe have a
more rounded answer for you all right
Tristan from Los Angeles I appreciate
the call
yeah thanks for having me all right
there he goes very powerful stuff let's
go to Kenny from Long Island Kenny
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today what can I do for you
Kenny from Long Island don't be the
first to drop you've got to accept my
invitation sir
oh boy
all right well that's too bad Kenny from
Long Island we are not going to hear
from today let's go to Gerald from Miami
now is that Miami Florida or Miami Ohio
Gerald please unmute so you can answer
my trivia questions
oh boy Gerald you're muting yourself
you've got to unmute yourself to be able
to talk to me can you hear me yes now I
can
oh hi uh
that's true General's from Miami Florida
great what's on your mind
oh yeah um I was just curious about you
know there's been a lot of uh talk
recently about uh upcoming like
Republican candidates you know that are
all jumping into the race for 2024 and I
know Biden has announced that he would
be running
um but I was curious if you had thought
about any other potential like
Democratic nominees that you know would
have a shot if they were to jump in the
race I don't think any would have a shot
really yeah I mean listen this if this
were an Open Primary here's the thing
people need to understand
I I support people challenging Joe Biden
I would like there to be debates on the
Democratic side if people credibly
challenged Joe Biden and are polling at
least you know some number eight percent
or something which right now I think
means at minimum you would have debates
between Biden and uh Bobby Kennedy Jr I
don't know where Marianne Williamson is
polling but I'm I'm in favor of debates
I'm in favor of a contested primary I
want people to run but if you're asking
me given what is going on and the fact
that the DNC is not incentivized to have
someone challenge the incumbent
president and that there's not going to
be a real primary I don't think there's
anyone who would have a shot I mean if
if we picked someone within with Mass
public appeal like I don't know if
Dwayne The Rock Johnson announced would
he be able to generate enough interest
because he's charismatic and whatever
that maybe he could actually defeat
Biden some I I just think that when you
have an incumbent president
the
um the odds that have to be overcome
because when you're an incumbent the DNC
is going to grease the wheels for you to
remain the nominee I don't know that
anybody could defeat Joe Biden given the
way that this primary is going to happen
ah I see yeah yeah it's just you know I
I've just been thinking I just
I just feel like you know with Joe
Biden's approval just kind of sinking I
just didn't know if he would uh
honestly I didn't I don't really think
he could actually win again to be honest
with you well listen I mean Biden's
approval it's not really sinking Biden's
approval has been steady since August of
of last year okay so that now is nine
months where it's just been in the low
40s when you and I look at that we say
oh that's pretty low that means like
high 50s disapproves of the job Biden is
doing yeah that's the way it is with
presidents in the United States right
now the reality is that you can
absolutely get yourself re-elected with
a 43 approval rating we saw George W
bush do it you know it's it's not
Biden's approval is not the sign to me
that he's in trouble
ah okay all right yeah I appreciate it
um thank you all right Gerald from Miami
uh great uh great question good to hear
from you